hi i'm priyanka vergaria and in this
video we will see what are hyper
parameters how to tune them and set up a
hyperparameter tuning job in vertex ai
all right so what is a hyperparameter
when a training application handles
three categories of data as it trains
the model the input data which is also
called training data contains the
features that the model uses to make
predictions now but this data is never
directly part of the model architecture
itself the second type of data is model
parameters these are the variables that
our ml model or technique uses to adjust
the data for example a deep neural
network or dnn is composed of processing
nodes or neurons each with an operation
performed on the data as it travels
through the network now when our dnn is
trained each node has a weight value
that tells our model how much impact it
has on the final prediction now they are
what distinguishes our particular model
from other models of the same
architecture trained on different data
now the third type of data is hyper
parameters and these are the variables
that govern the training process itself
for example a part of designing a deep
neural network is deciding how many
hidden layers you would want the input
between the input and the output to be
and how many nodes each hidden layer
would use like here i have two then
three then three but this could be any
number of nodes these variables are not
directly related to the training data
and they are the configuration variables
for your model now when it comes to
model parameters they can change with
the training job but hyper parameters
are usually going to stay constant which
means in our deep neural network model
example finding the right number of
hidden layers means choosing a value of
the number of hidden layers
training a model evaluating it with
those values and then trying it again
with a different value
now if we were to get the best hyper
parameter settings manually it could get
pretty tedious pretty quickly
that's where vertex ai hyper parameter
tuning comes in it is an automated
process of tuning hyper parameter jobs
as you're running your multiple trials
of the training application with values
of the chosen hyper parameters set
within the limits that you specify
and to select hyper parameters that give
the best performance vertex ai uses the
bayesian optimization for hyper
parameter tuning if you're interested in
the math behind it i've included a link
below to learn more about it with that
let's jump into the console and train a
hyper parameter tuning job
here i am in the google cloud console
first you need to enable compute engine
and container registry apis
in this demo i'm training and tuning an
image classification model trained on
the horses or humans data set from
tensorflow data sets
we will need a notebook to containerize
our training application code since i'm
creating a tensorflow model in this
example i'm going to select a tensorflow
enterprise 2.5 notebook without a gpu
but you can train a model built with any
framework using custom or pre-built
containers so select the notebook
accordingly
i already created one here so let's just
hop into that
in the terminal i created a folder
called horses or humans and inside that
folder i've created a docker file this
docker file uses deep learning container
tensorflow enterprise 2.5 gpu docker
image and the deep learning containers
on google cloud actually come with many
common machine learning and data science
frameworks that are pre-installed we're
also installing the hypertune library
here which we will use later to report
the metrics we want to optimize on
vertex ai
after downloading the image the docker
file sets up the entry point for the
training code
then i created the trainer folder with
task.py file and added the code for
training and tuning the model let's take
a deeper look at this code now
there are a few components that are
specific to using hyperparameter tuning
service
the script imports the hypertune library
we installed this library in the docker
file we created earlier and the function
get args defines a command line argument
for each hyper parameter that you want
to tune in this example the hyper
parameters that will be tuned are the
learning rate the momentum value in the
optimizer and the number of neurons in
the last hidden layer of the model but
feel free to experiment with others as
well
the value passed in these arguments is
then used to set the corresponding
parameters in the code at the end of
main function the hypertune library is
used to define the metric you want to
optimize in terms of flow the keras
model.fit method returns a history
object
the history.history attribute is a
record of training loss values and
metrics values at successive epochs
if you pass validation data to model.fit
the history.history attribute will
include validation loss and metrics
values as well
if you want the hyperparameter tuning
service to discover the values that
maximize the model's validation accuracy
you define the metric as the last entry
or num epochs as -1 of the val accuracy
list
then pass this metric to an instance of
hypertune
you can pick whatever string you like
for the hyperparameter metric tag i am
setting it to accuracy here but you will
need to use the same string again later
when you kick off the hyper parameter
tuning job
now we're ready to build the container
set the project id image uri and build
the container using the image uri
once the container is built push it to
the container registry
and then next let's head into the vertex
ai console and create a model to run our
hyperparameter tuning job
to configure a training job select no
manage data set custom training give the
model a name and then select the custom
container that we just created from our
notebook
notice that here i'm using custom
training via custom container on google
cloud container registry
but you can also run a hyper parameter
tuning job with the pre-built containers
in the next step enable hyper parameter
tuning add learning rate which would be
double min and max values and log
scaling
another parameter which was momentum
type would be double minimum and maximum
values linear scaling and third
hyperparameter would be our number of
neurons
discrete type and a value and no scaling
for this one
next we need to provide the metric we
want to optimize as well as the goal
this should be the same as our
hyperparameter metric tag we said in the
training application it was set to
accuracy and our goal is to maximize it
the vertex ai hyperparameter tuning
service will run multiple trials of our
training application with these values
you will need to put an upper bound on
the number of trials this service will
run for demo purposes i'm adding 15 here
more trials generally lead to better
results but there will be a point of
diminishing returns after which
additional trials have little or no
effect on the metric you're trying to
optimize so it's always the best
practice to start with a smaller number
of trials and get a sense of how
impactful your chosen hyper parameters
are before scaling up to a larger number
of trials
now you also need to set an upper bound
on the number of parallel trials here
i'm setting this to three increasing the
number of parallel trials will reduce
the amount of time the hyperparameter
tuning job takes to actually run however
it can reduce the effectiveness of the
job overall this is because the default
tuning strategy uses results of previous
trials to inform the assignment of
values in the subsequent trials so if
you run too many trials in parallel
there will be trials that start without
the benefit of the results from the
trial that are still running
now the last step is to select the
search algorithm now grid search is a
very traditional technique for
implementing hyper parameters it's a
brute force combines all the
combinations
now random search randomly samples the
search space and evaluates the sets for
specified probability distribution for
example instead of trying to check all
the hundred thousand samples we can
check thousand random sample parameters
we will select default search regarding
them here which will use google vizier
to perform bayesian optimization for
hyperparameter tuning to learn more
about how this works see the
documentation below in compute and
pricing leave the selected region as is
and configure worker pool 0 with a
machine type accelerator and disk size
now note here that selecting gpu is
totally optional hyper parameter tuning
job will just take a little longer to
complete if you do not use a gpu
then start the training it should take
about 45 minutes to train with the demo
parameters that i've selected here
and when it's finished you will be able
to click on the job name and see the
results of the tuning trials
from the results of our trial we can see
here that setting the learning rate to
3.9 momentum to 2.8 and neurons to 128
results in the highest validation
accuracy
in this video we've learned what is
hyperparameter tuning how vertex ai
helps automate the hyperparameter tuning
process and then we launched a hyper
parameter tuning job for training code
in custom container via the ui if you
would like to do the same using vertex
python sdk i have linked the code lab
below give it a try let me know how it
goes and for any questions reach out to
me on twitter at pee vergaria